today we are checking out the dji pocket
2.
i loved the first version of this and
i'm so excited to see that they have a
brand new
updated one the dji pocket 2. we have
two different combinations here we have
the regular pocket 2 with just the
camera and we have
the creator combo kit should i
get my new knife
then i have to go get the knife it's
probably worth it it's probably worth it
check this out
this one is actually for jenna my sister
and i'm gonna unbox this one so when
jenna comes over
we're gonna surprise her with her gift
you think i can open it now
okay i'm going to hurt myself
[Music]
oh looky a little clip
oh we're gonna have fun with this
look at this
if this isn't the smallest tiniest
cutest tripod i've ever seen
okay so here's the camera
so it does look pretty similar to the
previous version
kind of has that same form factor so the
bottom comes off
oh look at that so you can switch out
the bottom pieces and now i can
mount my little tiny tripod i still
can't get over how cute that is
i love the little carrying case that
they have for it what does this all come
with
there are so many things jam-packed
in this little box look at this
this gives you an even wider field of
view
wow this is a really great combo they've
included a lot of really awesome things
these are two adapters that you can use
to connect to your smartphone they have
a usbc and a lightning connector
this is cool because you can actually
connect this right to your smartphone so
you basically just plug it right in here
this is kind of a little smart port here
this will allow you to use your phone as
a monitor and you can also adjust
settings but
you don't need to use your phone this
also is a standalone camera
just like this this is a really neat
attachment this is a little
tiny joystick this will allow you to
have way more precise movements with
your camera
did we talk about the tripod yet i don't
know if we did because it's really
freaking cute
i love it the bottom of the device is
also modular so we already installed
this little tripod base and this is what
they're calling the
do-it-all handle so this gives you a
usbc port and a 3.5 millimeter
jack as well so this kind of i guess
will let you do it all
i care a couple options i don't know if
it's all
but this is a little wireless microphone
transmitter this little
windsock can go right on top of here so
you can use this to clip onto yourself
but i
plan on using this to annoy my sister
not my sister jenna but my sister
brienne
i'm about to travel for the first time
in seven months i just got my negative
coveted test
so i am going to visit my family and i'm
really excited because i'm going to be
using this to annoy my other sister
brienne and i'm going to be doing some
interviews with her
i'm going to get real up close
now i want to show you just a really
quick comparison to the previous version
a lot of the accessories for the
previous one will work with this
here is the previous version oh this had
like a little
like a little uh seat belt for it
no more seat belt this also feels like
it's a heavier duty plastic
and this one had a nice little felt
inside
to it this one also has a nice soft
little inside it's like a little blanket
so much like this one it also has the
little lcd on it
it has a smart connector the bottom of
the old one isn't modular so all of
these new accessories
will not work with it so that's
definitely something that i like that
they took into consideration
is the fact that we do need to have
these accessories we do want to have a
tripod
and this i think they've addressed a lot
of those concerns
what i do want to see is if this will
fit
in that case with my tripod on it or
that one bottom on it
yes i like this so they made this case
with this open bottom so that if you do
have any of these extended accessories
on
it'll still fit inside of the case
that's cool so while they do look pretty
similar there are some new updated
features about the new pocket too and
so far without even turning this on yet
i'm such a huge fan of these modular
bottoms this is going to really change
the game as far as creating content
the main new feature is the camera's
hardware it's been updated with a wider
field of view and better image quality
when shooting landscape and portraits it
has four microphones the new dji
matrix stereo feature supports stereo
recording soundtrack
wind noise reduction and more there's
also some new intelligent features like
an ai
editor to make an easily edited video
for you there's a bunch of accessories
like the do-it-all handle wireless
microphone micro tripod and mini control
stick it shoots 4k
ultra hd 2k and full hd at 24
25 30 48 and 60 frames a second
so about a year ago i was doing a video
with the osmo pocket the previous
version
and now i'm doing another one and i was
filming my sister brie
and she had a baby in the belly and now
guess what
baby's out of the belly and she's a year
old why are you on this side look at
bree's belly
she didn't want to show it today oh hi
brandon say hi
say hi say hi this is a pocket size
camera just like you
pocket size this is two this is the new
version
whoa look at this shot
i'm holding it
i'm dizzy now
[Music]
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna run and see how
steady it is
i'm running i'm running
[Music]
i'm running i'm running oh my goodness
i'm testing out this little tiny
microphone it's wireless
so it connects right to this pocket too
we're gonna let's see how's that oh my
god this is so cool
let's go see if we can get an exclusive
interview with maddie
exclusive interview
speak what's that little thing let's
even get an exclusive interview with
jenna what's this little thing
this is in the creator kit who's creator
kit in the osmo
pocket 2 they have another version it's
like a little creator kit i'm shook
it's a wireless mic it's cool super cool
wow
fall is so pretty i can't believe it can
also connect to a log
so i can connect that inside the 3.5
millimeter
jack right there and it'll wirelessly
transmit to the pocket
man altitude no joke
so this is just my first test with the
pocket too
so far i'm super impressed i love the
extended handle i also love this little
microphone accessory
i think the fact that they've now put
this integrated tripod mount on the
bottom of this
is really exciting because it basically
makes it so much easier to mount it
places
and i can't wait to test this out a
little bit more
[Music]
you